an unexpected end to this belarusian
sprinter's olympic run
kristina timanovskaya is seeking asylum
at the polish embassy in tokyo
after she dared to criticize her
national coaching team on instagram
for submitting her into a race without
her consent
and then trying to force her to fly home
to an uncertain fate
she sought police protection at tokyo's
hanada airport as her husband
says he packed his bags and fled belarus
for ukraine
did you ever get the impression that
christina wanted to leave
belarus for good um
yes yes so this wasn't pre-planned
she was cast as hysterical but the
pressure was real
this leaked recording where she begs her
coaches not to make her go
a sinister insight into belarusian
athletics
back in belarus plenty of athletes have
suffered reprisals for supporting the
widespread opposition
to president lukashenko's 27 year rule
so much so there's a support group set
up for them based in
exile in lithuania we have seen examples
of thousands of people who've been
imprisoned for nothing
so i'm sure they would find an article
for christina
she now has a humanitarian visa and will
leave for poland in the coming days
when and if she'll ever get back to
belarus a very different story
diana magnay sky news moscow